170 millions d'euros qui sont un effort
supplémentaire qui sont mis aux
bénéfices effectivement des territoires
d'outre-mer dans leur développement et
dans l'accompagnement des projets des
territoires à travers notamment le fonds
exceptionnel d'investissement mais aussi
des fautes et des mesures qui sont à
destination des entreprises puisque vous
le savez les territoires d'outre-mer ont
véritablement besoin à travers après les
assises des outre-mer et c'est ce que
nous avons acté dans le livre bleu d'une
dynamique de développement économique
c'est un choix effectivement que je
porte que porte le gouvernement de
décider effectivement tu auras un effort
également qui viendra des territoires
d'outre-mer en dea à destination des
territoires d'outre-mer et la
participation des contribuables 4 % des
contribuables d'outre-mer ramènera 70
millions d'euros qui seront redistribués
en totalité dans les territoires
d'outre-mer au bénéfice de routes
d'écoles
je crois honnêtement que c'est faire
profiter de l'effort de l'état a plus
grand nombre de nos concitoyens au
bénéfice de la structuration de leur
territoire pour répondre à des besoins
d'école à des besoins de route à des
besoins de d'investissement de crèches
etc
et c'est important c'est un choix que
j'assume complètement